ciao amore tutto bene senti cosa
facciamo di ballo oggi solo la piega no
rovinati due caffè il nord di recco ge
di bellissimi capelli sono soltanto un
po stopposo fuori di un po dei rami
secchi da potare possiamo fare una
doppia rico la cretina più filler botox
enti crespo che dici il colore come lo
vedo amore lo vedo bene lo vedo così
bene che vi chiedo chi è il caso umano
che te l'ha fatto no ma ti giuro la
ricrescita guarda veramente
impercettibile proprio amore però si
cambi parrucchiere come cambi le
montagne non ti lamentare poi io farei
totalizzante riff restante brillantante
bondage vale jansch così togliamo questo
arancione vomitino che sulle punte
ascolta ma se facessimo un bel
cioccolato fondente che sulle punte
diventa al latte spuntarli noda alla
fine 20 centimetri di doppie punte non
si notano neanche però se insisti quanto
vuoi che i tagli 2 mm e mezzo
va bene ci penso io amore ma quali 20
centimetri dai io ho tagliato solo i
punti di un po rovinate e poi fidati che
ora piange ma più avanti vi ringrazierà
i